let's go to trace Gallagher with the
very latest on the investigation trace
the sheriff said that he couldn't tell
us all that he knows but you can bet
that he probably knows something does
that mean that they have more
information that they're letting on at
the moment
well it certainly means that the sheriff
has deeper into this investigation than
we were 24 hours ago today he really was
very forthright in a lot of the stuff
that he that he has kind of said to us I
mean fascinating information about
cameras inside the room he said there
were cameras both set up inside the
hotel room and outside the room even a
camera set up on a hotel service cart
though we don't know if that was inside
or outside the cameras outside clearly
meant to be able to give him a warning
if police were coming down the halls
it's unclear if the cameras inside the
room were actually setup to get him
shooting or get the actual firing on the
crowd below so the sheriff did not talk
about that but he did talk about the
fact that over the course of the four
days that Steven paddock was inside that
room that room service did go in that
room a number of times apparently
nothing set off alarm bells we should
also note that the sheriff was unhappy
you talked about the video
the sheriff was very unhappy about the
pictures being released about the
weapons we're talking about the rifles
on the floor after the attack at the
attack the sheriff did confirm that at
least one of those weapons and we have
heard many more were actually equipped
with something called a bump stock which
does something it replaces the shoulder
rest and what it does is it means that
the weapon still fires one shot at a
time but the bump stock means that it
just kind of automatically holds the
trigger
meaning the weapons can fire between
three hundred to seven 800 rounds per
minute this went on for nine to 11
minutes you can imagine the thousands
and thousands of rounds he fired off and
the sheriff's saying if they hadn't
gotten there sooner he had enough
weaponry to go on for a lot longer than
that he also made some very informative
decisions on the houses that the house
in Reno we now have learned they found
five guns they found in rifles and they
also found what he quoted as a plethora
of ammunition in that house you add to
that the mesquite house they found 19
weapons there explosives and they have
pulled out a whole bunch of electronics
and computer hard drives that's critical
to this investigation
because remember the hard drives is
where they will get all their
information on who Steven paddock was
having conversations with in the days
and weeks leading up to this and we
should finally let you know that the
sheriff has kind of backed into the
whole question of the girlfriend the
girlfriend member he said was in Tokyo
well now he's confirmed the girlfriend
was in Philippines in the Philippines
they have talked to her they are
actively in the process of bringing her
back here the sheriff did say she is a
person of interest they will be fully
investigating and he intimated that he
believes that she knows a lot more than
she's letting on
and finally you talked earlier about the
thousands of dollars tens of thousands
of dollars that were sent from the
shooter over to the Philippines we have
now confirmed that as well it's unclear
exactly who that money was intended for
but but now you can see where the
girlfriend is fully back a meshed in
this investigation as it goes forward
well trace is always super comprehensive
but we still have more questions for you
we're gonna take it around the table
here kimberly guilfoyle kicks us off all
right so trace um you know we talked
about the large number of you know
ammunition weapons that he built to
sniper nests and it's just very puzzling
and disturbing to me that nobody noticed
anything and thought that was suspicious
carrying in that level of equipment that
much ammunition making noise to kind of
set those two platforms up it's just a
lot of people have so many questions in
this case and then when you see law
enforcement allude to there's things
that they're holding back that they're
not going to tell us I mean especially
it seems with this case there's it seems
there's much more to this picture than
we're being told and I think you're
right Kimberly but in defense of luf Las
Vegas Metro Police they've been pretty
forthright I mean they've given us as
much information without trying to
compromise the investigation they have
given us a great deal of information as
this thing has kind of set forward I
will tell you though that it has brought
up your concern about how in the world
did he get I mean where he's talking
about ten suitcases of ammunition how do
you get that much ammunition 23 guns
inside the hotel room and someone
brought up well do we change security do
we have these
baggage bags go through some kind of a
security apparatus like they do in
Israel and that's an open question I
mean I think the answer to that is
probably not because it would it would
still be you know it make difficult a
difficult situation at the security
apparatus here in Vegas the millions of
people who come here year it would
really be hard to actually nail that
down but but it brings up a very good
point as for the guns themselves being
set up Kimberly and being aimed out the
window I mean you know 23 weapons inside
there dozens of other weapons at the
house he bought dozens of weapons
legally in Nevada and Utah over the
course of the past few years and one has
to ask this woman who lived with him in
these houses where they had explosives
they had ammonium nitrate in his car
ammonium nitrates used was what Tim
McVeigh used the Oklahoma City bombing
so if you're that woman and you live
with this man and he has all this
firepower you have to ask yourself did
she know more than she's letting on and
I think the answer for Las Vegas Metro
police is yeah I think she did trace
this very difficult cable news moves way
faster than an investigation and it's
like no matter what we ask you I don't
know if you're gonna have an answer to
it but the thing part one piece of this
is that like they said there were no
links to terror before they analyzed his
personal electronic devices isn't that
kind of premature I mean I'm inclined to
think it's not terror elated but if you
don't look at his personal electronic
devices when you say that that seems
really premature and you know it's a
fair point Greg but but what they're
talking about when they say no link to
terrorism about his social media
footprint and right now this guy's
social media footprint is just
non-existent yeah I mean he was a guy
who didn't have a Facebook account so
you know we know a lot about him
personally we know that his family says
that he had no religious or political
affiliation that there were no ties to
terrorism that he you know he didn't
make any of these outlandish comments so
that's what they were going by do they
believe that there might be something
that could take them down a different
road well the sheriff just said sure and
as they kind of look at all of this
stuff but they were saying in the early
going there was no automatic tide of
terrorism and if you look back at the
shootings that we have had over the past
several years
every time we get a name we match it
with the social footprint and within
hours we know right away that yes there
is something that indicates there was
some outside force playing into this and
in this case we simply didn't and the
bigger question Gregg is was this his
primary target did he plan to have a
more elaborate tack
I mean you throw in the ammonium nitrate
right as a bomb you throw in the
explosives up in the mesquite house and
that the reporting now that he may have
rented condos downtown in Las Vegas that
oversaw a different concert that was
held a week ago was he planning for a
different venue or was he planning on
this venue but a much more elaborate
attack that might be in those
communications that were brought out of
the various homes but but I think as you
know we try not to get our head of our
skis in this investigation we get a lot
of information a lot of it's wrong and
so we try at least to the best of our
knowledge to rely on our sources to
sources for every piece of information
and then relying on the sheriff when he
starts to confirm stuff that's why we
love you trace we're gonna go to Jesse
Watters next yeah something about this
still doesn't add up to me they were
very quick as Greg noted to rule out
everything they ruled out the accomplice
they ruled out Isis they ruled out what
no political affiliation yet did they
interview anybody that the girlfriend
talked to in the Philippines I don't
think so and they haven't done a full
interview of her yet they haven't you
say you know he doesn't know if media
footprint
he has electronic devices in his house
they haven't scrubbed those either
the guns haven't been fully traced so I
think there was a lot of put out in the
beginning to rule everything out which
worries me because now I feel like we're
backtracking especially after you look
at all the money that was wired overseas
now the father was a suicidal psychopath
who was on the FBI's most wanted list
and he was highly intelligent because he
was a bank robber and he was on the lam
for quite some time right there's also
maybe this guy just got bad DNA from his
dad he's also a psychopath he's very
methodical something clicked he looked
unbalanced that seems right now if you
if you take out all the other stuff they
ruled out to me at least that seems like
the only thing as
complex as this is that you can really
hang your hat on well just for
clarification Jesse they haven't really
ruled out a lot of things so they they
say that they haven't had the
information or the evidence to lead them
down this road so when they when you say
they're ruling things out
maybe the phrasing is they just don't
have enough evidence to take him in that
direction right now so when it comes to
the girlfriend they said earlier they
said you know the morning after the
shooting that there's no evidence to
suggest she was a part of this at all we
don't think she has any longer a person
of interest and you're exactly right
they came back six hours later saying
you know what she is a person of
interest and yes we are interviewing her
and yes we want to find out what she was
doing in the Philippines at this very
time and today even took it a step
forward saying yeah not only was she in
the Philippines but we are actively
trying to bring her back because we
believe that there's more to this whole
story than we first thought about maybe
they know more about these electronics
they're pulling out of the home but I
think you know in fairness they're not
really ruling out all of these things
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to take piece by piece that the
investigation take the weapons take the
explosives take the people that have
talked to them in the family and see if
they can put this puzzle together try
and come up with some kind of a
motivation which right now he said at
the top of this news conference they
simply do not have a motive for why he
would do that will they find one the
sheriff said yes we will find a motive
do they have one right now not that he
told us Jesse Williams hi tre so I'm
curious too about the gunman and one
things that I was reading about today in
the papers was that recently he had been
involved in gambling transactions that
tipped the ten thousand dollar mark so
that required some government
notification it also said that he was an
investor in commercial I think actually
residential real estate in Dallas and
finally that what was so interesting to
me is that he had worked for both the
IRS and Lockheed Martin so then the
thought occurred to me well could it be
that he had some financial difficulties
is that possible that his gambling was
not going well because he's often
described as a professional game
it's very possible whining there's two
prongs to that investigation first of
all you talk about the financial
difficulties well look you run it down
yeah he was a he was a letter carrier
here was a mailman in his early career
worked for the IRS worked for Lockheed
Martin and yes he invested in real
estate we know he has a home in Mesquite
Texas we know he has a home in Mesquite
Nevada as well as Reno and in Central
Florida as well so these are all
properties that he owned he didn't have
renters so clearly he had enough
financial ability to pay for these homes
without having them rented out we also
know that in fact he was sending tens of
thousands of dollars overseas to the
Philippines so he had enough liquid
finances to be able to do that was he
gambling sure it's on record you have to
notify the government we know that in
recent weeks he has placed exorbitant
bets ten twenty thirty thousand dollars
you have to get the bets on record we
don't know whether he won or lost
I mean his brother would often say look
he would call him and say yeah I made
this much money gambling I did very well
gambling he considered himself a
professional gambler that's how he made
his living but he also had a lot of
investments was he broke we don't know
because we don't know if he won or lost
the bets but it all indications are that
he was still fairly liquid was still
doing pretty well
no foreclosure notices on his planes his
homes and he was sending tens of
thousands of dollars in cash so all
signs point to the fact that financially
he did not seem destitute yeah I was
just going to say that when I was
thinking about the money being sent to
the Philippines that doesn't say who
it's going to and so we I think the
assumption was it's going to this woman
but she could just very easily be a
cover he could be sending money to a
foreign a foreign group I mean we know
what's going on in the Philippines right
now I mean there's a possibility that he
could be doing that he could be simply
trying to hide money from the IRS yeah
yeah it could be but remember there was
no escape plan here so you're trying to
hide money from the IRS you know here
there was no there was no way out of
this he didn't leave himself an escape
plan there's it's not like he was saying
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot as many
people as I can I'm gonna haul out the
back door and go to the Philippines I
think that the mentality here was
different
he was sending this money for some
reason
and we don't know exactly what the
reason is but to think that he was was
trying to shelter it in some capacity I
don't think there's any indication of
that so far but we don't have the
electronics we don't have the you know
the computer hard drives that they are
now mulling over and actively looking at
to find out exactly what his motivation
is for doing all this stuff the gambling
the money overseas that the looking at
different condominiums in downtown Las
Vegas over a different concert the
ammonium nitrate in the car there are so
many different aspects and facets to
this investigation we don't have answers
for we're just kind of going step by
step with the Metro Police Department
all right trace Gallagher thank you so
much